[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show there's a very
interesting new study which finds that
moderna
causes the generation of twice as many
antibodies as pfizer we're talking about
the modernicovit vaccine and the pfizer
covid vaccine
this is a belgian study published in
jama one of the top medical journals and
it measured antibody levels after the
second shot so
there's there's a couple of different
stories actually here pat the first
story is
moderna has three times the oh what's
the term i want to make sure i get the
exact right term the moderna vaccine has
three times
oh i don't want to say the mrna quantity
but the moderna vaccine has more
material in it than the pfizer vaccine
and you end up with about twice as many
antibodies if you've been vaccinated
with moderna versus pfizer okay great
but what does it mean we don't know and
this actually came up in my interview
today with vincent racaniello
i just played a trump drop accidentally
my finger slipped um this came up with
vincent racanello who said
yes antibodies decline after eight
months but does it actually reduce your
level of protection in the same way
imagine that you need a level of i'm
just making up numbers if you need a
hundred antibodies to be immune and
pfizer gives you 200 and moderna gives
you 400 are you really any better off
with moderna we just don't know all we
know now pat is the antibody level seems
to be twice as high with moderna okay so
this could be why they're both about 90
efficacious against infections but long
term we may not know necessarily which
one's better if the antibodies in one
are waning more so than in the other i
mean it would be good to know and you
know as time goes on we'll find out more
about this stuff if moderna does turn
out to be the superior vaccine you could
say then maybe we would target
immunosuppressed people with that one
specifically maybe we could have a
situation where if you took the pfizer
vaccine you need a booster shot but not
necessarily if you took the moderna
vaccine could be and we'll just have to
find out i mean we thought that maybe
these vaccines were basically clones of
one another and it was very similar the
modern and the pfizer one whereas the
johnson and johnson vaccine and some of
these other ones were quite different uh
but you know now we're starting to see
different tiers with all these vaccines
as time goes on yeah and again if it's
as simple as the moderna vaccine
contains more and again i don't remember
if it's mrna or what it contains more of
but it is essentially a clone it's just
a clone with more stuff that seems like
a simple modification to make to the
pfizer as well now the study did find
that um the moderna vaccine
was associated with a greater reduction
against breakthrough infections now as
we get more data
about vaccine
fully vaccinated infections the early
data is you are better off with moderna
as far as that goes but this is still
early there's a lot still to learn i
imagine that in a year we're going to
know so much more than we know right now
i wonder if this will change the
recommendations for people who haven't
yet gotten the vaccine like if you held
out for this long you're a vaccine
hesitant maybe some of those people will
decide to take the moderna one because
they'll consider it to be more effective
maybe there's less of a chance of them
having to take a third shot in the
future because their antibodies won't
wane as much uh we'll see if any of that
sort of thing happens but uh you must
feel somewhat vindicated right because
you got the moderna vaccine whereas i
got the pfizer vaccine vindicated
which vaccine you had yeah moderna was
the one that was available to you and so
of course you took it but it turns out
pretty well
yeah i mean listen
i i'm i
given this study
i i'm glad i guess i got them a dinner
but it feels weird even to say because i
just got what was available to me at the
time you know
yeah exactly i did the same thing with
the pfizer vaccine that was the one that
i could get and so i took it uh so i
guess there's maybe more of a chance of
me getting a breakthrough case than is
then if i had gotten the modern vaccine
instead unfortunately but that's okay
because i'm still protected against
severe covet against hospitalization and
certainly death and so i'm happy with
that if i have to take a booster shot in
a few months sign me up for it i don't
mind by the way this was not on the
agenda but i'm just curious
i i'm sure you saw rogan has coveted and
took like seven medications like
what's
you don't take seven medications if
something's no big deal right like
that's my main reaction right and his
big thing this whole time was that you
just have to be healthy so that if you
do get coveted then you're not going to
get a severe case of coving yeah joe
rogan is super healthy right he works
out all the time um and you know he eats
a good diet and all this stuff and yet
he got it and it sounded like he was
really sick for a day and now he's on
seven different medications and it also
sounds like he's playing coy about his
vaccination status like see i didn't
think whether or not he's gotten it
that's interesting i i assume i i
address this a little bit on the podcast
i just assume he hasn't gotten
vaccinated because i think if he had he
would have said even though i'm
vaccinated this happened and i i just
assume he's not been vaccinated i assume
so as well given the statements that
he's made about how younger healthier
people shouldn't have to take the
vaccine although he is in his 50s he is
in his 50s yeah um but you know maybe he
doesn't want to turn off a segment of
his right wing audience who watches him
like that's a big deal with audience
capture and all that stuff so maybe he
did get vaccinated but doesn't want to
say so
um also if he did get vaccinated would
he have had such a severe case of kobe
because it did sound like it was pretty
bad for a while so my guess is that he
wasn't vaccinated but who knows i think
you have to go back on his podcast
pretty soon i would go back on any time
i i think there i think possibility a is
he hasn't seen anything i've said all
this time about his stuff on vaccines
possibility b as he has and he's upset
with me about it i don't know
what makes me think he's seen it is when
he interviewed i don't remember if it
was glenn greenwald or
jimmy dore no he was interviewing a
comedian and he said
i really think what glenn greenwald and
jimmy dore doing you know they're doing
reporting they're really doing original
reporting and that's great you know the
people who are just kind of like giving
hot takes and that was like three days
after we did the vaccine clip in my head
i was wondering is he referring to my
clip about his vaccination take i don't
know yeah he could be he could be uh it
does sound like he's skewing a little
bit more to the right as time goes on
like i remember a few years ago he had
all these right wing guests on and then
he talked about how just left-wingers
don't really want to come on his podcast
but then a bunch of lefties reached out
uh including you and said hey we're
happy to come on and then he had more
and more
left-wing people on he said that he
supported bernie sanders but i don't
know ever since he moved to texas it
seems like he's going back in the
opposite direction where he's having
more right wingers on yeah being
skeptical of cobit and the vaccine and
all this stuff so you know at least he
is malleable like maybe he can uh turn
that around once again i assume if i win
a strange character i assume if i went
in there we would basically agree about
almost anything now that doesn't about
almost everything on this stuff that
doesn't necessarily mean his mind would
be changed i just think
the way i would present things he would
just be like that all sounds reasonable
but then you have someone with opposite
views go on and he's like that all
sounds reasonable that is a common
criticism of joe rogan that he'll just
agree with whatever the guest says
every now and then he'll debate but he
just wants to go along to get along it
sounds like a lot of the time so that
could be what's happening there so
that's the latest there all right let's
move on illinois is doing something
that's really great illinois is becoming
the first state to require media
literacy classes for high school
students this is going to be
a requirement that you learn
how do you consume media how do you
discern fact from fiction
and that is going to start not this year
but what the
2223 year that starts in september of
2022
there will be instruction given to
students
how do you analyze information from
various media including digital
interactive audio visual and print
how does media affect information
consumption how does the media affect
human emotions how does it affect human
behavior the devil is in the details
we'll see more about the specifics but
this is exactly what i've been calling
for for a decade now on the program this
is what this is what would be great for
everybody to have
yep this is right up your alley and
unfortunately republicans in the state
of illinois did not support this right
the legislation passed the house 68 to
44 but no republicans voted in favor of
it in the house and then in the senate
the vote was 42-15 with only three
republicans voting in favor of it with
15 republicans voting against this and i
wonder why i mean i guess they would say
that this is just indoctrinate
indoctrination that uh schools want to
teach everyone that uh these sort of
left-wing liberal media sources are okay
whereas the right-wing sources are not
okay right but that's not what this is i
suppose maybe they would come up with an
excuse like you know if we're going to
teach media literacy that means we have
to take out something else from the
curriculum and you know maybe that would
be a little bit more legitimate of an
argument but it's not like it's one of
those one-size-fits-all solutions where
okay we're going to take out shop class
or home economics or whatever else it is
you know it just sounds like the schools
will be able to implement this and take
out from the curriculum whatever else
they want to and uh it sounds to me just
like they are playing into this
narrative that they're trying to
indoctrinate your children of course
liberal media and all this stuff and
that's all this is that's all it is yeah
it's the same as you know when they were
talking a few years ago about college
has become left-wing indoctrination
media literacy they they believe or they
claim i don't know if they really
believe it they claim will also be
left-wing indoctrination by the way
why is it called home economics when you
learn like sewing and stuff like that
i've never understood that
right and yeah sometimes it's shortened
to home eck yeah uh but yeah and i never
had that class myself i always like i
saw it in sitcoms and that sort of thing
growing up where students would have to
take a home economics class and i know
it was more in vogue like decades ago
that people would have to learn about
those those topics but yeah if it's like
sewing and cooking and all these things
it's really not economics and you know
someone with an economics background i
think you can attest to that it's not
and i had a homemade class in middle
school and i remember we sewed duffel
bags
i don't remember anything else we did it
couldn't have been just a sewing class
like it must have been something else
but i don't really know i'm sure if i
googled it why is it called homec i'm
sure we would learn you know what would
be really great in home economics if
people were taught personal finance how
to understand mortgage interest rates
leasing versus buying a car
how to
how different retired like retirement
plans work that would be a fantastic
thing to be teaching yep that's the
other thing that we have to enter into
school curricula
financial literacy right there needs to
be a financial literacy class if we have
a media literacy class and a financial
literacy class in our curricula across
the
school systems in the united states i
think that would be absolutely terrific
because yeah i mean you leave high
school and some some degree college too
if you don't take up finance and
economics and all this stuff without
knowing about all these things like
saving for retirement compound interest
which is really important for young
people to learn about how to balance
your checkbook and all these different
things i mean taxes is another thing
that students aren't taught about and uh
you know i wonder why that is especially
at this late stage when we know that
it's such an important issue um you know
maybe it's because you have to remove
something else from the curriculum but
like it just seems so obvious to me that
it's
so obvious and good for illinois as some
people like to pronounce it uh we'll see
what the implementation is
this is a really weird story
oklahoma congressman mark wayne mullen
was essentially missing until yesterday
morning
and he reportedly threatened embassy
workers in tajikistan
while attempting to enter afghanistan
which borders tajikistan to rescue five
u.s citizens like he was personally
there
and yesterday morning mullen posted to
social media that he's quote heading
home
and confirmed he was trying to help
americans leave afghanistan
and saying that he is not actually
missing
he stated that his mission continues
although like it's not really clear why
he specifically is involved he claims
that because the us under biden did so
poorly he's disappointed in terms of
leaving americans behind
he went to tajikistan and then into
afghanistan to try to get people out
it's all very very strange
yeah it's super strange i mean maybe
he's just trying to make a point maybe
he's trying to appeal to his right-wing
constituents i mean maybe there is
something somewhat admirable about it
because like i certainly wouldn't enter
afghanistan now to do such a thing but
he was willing to even though he's
privileged and a lawmaker and all this
other stuff i mean maybe it's just to
play up his uh you know his personal
cachet or whatever but yeah i don't
entirely understand why someone would go
about doing this um maybe he really did
just want to rescue people who knows
what's going on with him this is
actually the second time he tried to
enter afghanistan he traveled to greece
last week to ask permission to go into
afghanistan and was denied by the
pentagon according to an administration
official and he's been tweeting about
how americans u.s citizens in
afghanistan have been left to quote fend
for themselves as terrorists are running
the country he talked about the military
motto leave no man behind
and on and on um it it's it's all
very very strange um there are a couple
other members of congress who did travel
to afghanistan last month congressman
seth moulton and peter meyer
went to afghanistan to observe the chaos
that was starting to unfold and nancy
pelosi said this is really not a good
idea i would not be going to afghanistan
right now and and i know that we could
say well the guy is brave for doing it
it all seems kind of short-sighted and
harebrained
right
yeah it's super risky and you need
lawmakers themselves going over there i
suppose they could say that you can't
trust the biden administration on all
this stuff because they would argue that
the biden administration and the
pentagon right now are handling all this
super poorly so members of congress have
to do it themselves there's no choice
that's questionable as well and also
there's this big question mark over
whether or not we really have all these
americans who still want to leave
afghanistan because there are still
americans in afghanistan but many of
them are dual citizens some of them
don't want to leave um and but like a
lot of that information we're trusting
uh the pentagon with
administration and you know you could be
critical of that you could say well of
course that's what they're saying
because they had this big failure or at
least you could say the withdrawal has
been tumultuous and so that's why
they're trying to say that there aren't
that many american citizens we just
don't know what we were told as of two
days ago is that it's under 200 and
probably under 100 american citizens
who want to leave and that's a key point
and joe biden saying in the speech a
couple of days ago
as you're pointing out a lot of these
folks are citizens of afghanistan as
well as the u.s and they're not trying
to leave they're trying to be there with
their families so i don't imagine that
if they're wrong they're wrong by
thousands like maybe it's not a hundred
maybe it's 350
but it's not 20 000 americans that are
currently trying to get out yeah and if
people want to get out even at this late
stage we should do what we can to help
them yeah but i don't think it's really
scalable for members of congress to go
over there in helicopters and fly them
out one by one it's sort of like saying
we need we need john travolta to fly
over there and fly people back in his
plane like okay maybe he could do that
but that's not really policy or strategy
yeah i'm getting a lot of delusions of
grandeur vibes from this story i think
he's trying to be like rambo or some
other movie star by doing this um i you
know can we commend him for trying like
i don't even know sure sort of mixed
about it why not yeah i know i'm unsure
as well or are we sort of like are we
condoning
kind of risky behavior by doing it but
the big news is although he was believed
missing for two days
apparently his office was just being
hush-hush assuming they knew
about what he was doing
maybe for the perception of his his own
safety so that's the latest with mark
wayne mullen
um okay that does it for today if you
missed yesterday's live stream with dr k
and jimmy from philly
we are putting together what we hope
will be an okay edit of it this is
probably the craziest situation we've
had with having to edit an interview
during the interview jimmy from philly
was using both a bong and whippets
neither of which is allowed on twitch or
youtube by terms of service so we've had
to to remove that
it's i think it'll still be pretty
coherent right pat oh yeah totally uh we
just had to blur out certain segments of
it there's also vaping and smoking
cigarettes during the entire thing which
is allowed that's okay for youtube but
it makes me really concerned for jimmy's
uh personal physical health of course
and especially if he's doing that stuff
all the time and not just for an
appearance that maybe he was a little
anxious over uh you know if he really is
chain smoking and all that stuff all the
time then he really needs to see a
doctor yeah and dr k asked do you have a
doctor and jimmy said he he does
um so anyway we're going to be
publishing that today check it out i got
a lot of positive messages about it in
different ways
so that'll be published and then we'll
be back with a brand new show tomorrow